alors que l'arrivée et le déploiement de
la 5g ne fait toujours pas l'unanimité
on revient ce soir sur la finalisation
de la couverture 4g
aujourd'hui les départements du loir et
cher et de l'indre et loire sont
couverts à 99% par cette technologie
un argument de taille notamment pour les
communes rurales et qui peuvent
permettre à leurs habitants de
télétravailler retour sur ce maillage
devenu indispensable au fil du temps
avec florent clavel sous la pluie loir
et chérienne on inaugure ce matin une
antenne de téléphonie mobile oui car ici
à selles sur cher
ce mât haut de trente mètres c'est
l'arrivée de la 4g
autrement dit de l'internet rapide sur
son téléphone
un petit événement dans un contexte
comme on a connu actuellement avec des
gens qui télétravaillent je pense que
c'est quelque chose qui est très
appréciable comme selles sur cher c'est
l'ensemble du val de loire qui connaît
une accélération du déploiement de la 4g
orange l'une des quatre principales
entreprises du secteur à implanter dix
huit antennes en loir-et-cher rien que
l'année dernière 9 en indre et loire
aujourd'hui donc pratiquement 99% des
loir et chérien on
l'accès à la 4g par orange en cinq ans
la couverture 4g
que ce soit ici en indre et loire ou en
loir-et-cher a été multiplié par plus de
deux
aujourd'hui la quasi totalité du
territoire est couverte pour les
communes
un enjeu d'attractivité en termes de
développement on va dire économique même
si c'est un grand bond à l'heure
actuelle c'est quand même toujours très
intéressant d'avoir la 4g pour les
entreprises ont fait pas venir
d'entreprise si on n'a pas tout ce
système de déployer des installations
qui serviront ensuite au déploiement de
la 5g deux opérateurs la propose déjà en
val de loire
mais à des débits parfois à belle bleue
puissant que l'actuel 4g